signori siccome voglio fare le cose
fatte bene visto che vi è piaciuto così
tanto cyberpunk volevo fare un secondo
episodio perché merita l'ultima volta
avevo fatto cioè ero arrivato a porca
vacca aspetta ma non mi ricordavo
partisse così stretto ratio dicevo
l'ultima volta mi è capitato di vincere
troppo troppo troppo troppo in fretta
perché vabbè ormai era diventato esperto
adesso ci sono un sacco di ladri
ecco infatti che stanno sparando un
sacco rispetto all'altra volta va bene e
voglio provare a vedere fino a che punto
rischia di varie ora che sono un po più
esperto insomma visto che l'ultima volta
è stato e l'ultima volta un tutorial ok
adesso facciamo le cose fatte bene vedo
che questi hanno imparato a fare
moonwalk con michael jackson
calmati perfetto non ci passo allora non
è proprio ho beccato l'altro che non
c'entra niente non è proprio il massimo
ragazzi e ricominciare subito con 5 di
stilisti qua perché effettivamente se è
passato un po di tempo dall'ultima volta
non mi ricordo manco vicomandi quindi
scusatemi se sarò un po impicciato ma è
normale ragazzi e così almeno per questo
orca vacca sembrerà molto di giocare a
dark souls in questa primavera
purtroppo raga non posso fare altrimenti
però fan madonna che mi la brutta in
show non regga non ci credo sono scarso
con la morte
allora ho questo lo presto
oh mio dio non è proprio fisica questa
occhio hanno preso delle robe di valore
via via via via via via elia devo perché
io devo evitare che loro prendano le
corse di valore
c'è l'obiettivo è questione solo farli
fuori quindi teoricamente fammi passare
eccoti mamma la porta con la finestra
uno li charge
ma vedi che io possa uccidere la gente o
no non li apprezza spain sturam vuol
dire taglia ma non funziona niente non
ho capito non solo l'hack è male pensare
cosa devo fare
ok con loro mangiato però poi mi ha
tirato un calcio sono morto e non è
facile quando da un po che non ci giochi
allora ragazzi non ho veramente capito
se tutti i tasti che sto usando del
rombo che si chiama così se sono tutti
quelli giusti perché teoricamente siamo
messi potrebbero fare molte più cose
solo che sono io che sono nato e non le
so però vabbè ma vai col fuoco che non
ho ancora capito come squadra mi sono
incastrato ok non ho ancora capito come
faccio la cala del fuoco visto che non è
proprio tecnologica qualcosa ma niente
scuse ciò vale niente non l'ho preso vai
col clacson michael jackson occhio
occhio occhio passate qua vicino al
fuoco di nuovo tutti very good
madonna crociata mamma mia ragazzi ho
fatto un casino
stavolta ho fatto la lampada ma c'è
qualcosa con la lampada io non sapevo ma
dai ma può esplorare la lampada porca
vacca non lo sapevo mai fatto sull'osso
livello perché veramente merica troppo
madonna cosa è successo ragazzi qualcuno
ha tirato un calcio qualcuno ed e non ho
capito cosa sia successo però e sono ste
robe va bene via occhio con la presa
elettrica che fa sempre un danno
incredibile
molto bene vieni giovanni vieni che c'è
l'acqua qua
bravo ancora avanti avanti avanti avanti
avanti occhio ora teoricamente se tutto
va bene faccio esplodere sa fare che
succede ma se succede a catena che si
fanno male tutti che non ho capito
porca vacca oggi non l'ho marcato come
ok morto venite qua ma chi è che si sta
facendo ma chi è che fa male agli altri
se qualcuno ragazzi che fa mara gli
altri non riesco a capire se si pigliano
danno in faccia e basta ma caso che
questo è morto molto bene family
friendly con questo gioco perfetto
dovrei aver fatto fuori tutti
teoricamente se la matematica non
inganna però mi ha sempre ingannato
anche a scuola quindi perché non anche
qua
vieni quasi io vi dico addio che c'è un
po di sopravviverà 1 innanzitutto
perfetto poi c'è l'acqua teoricamente se
vi dico a doversi scadere sull'acqua
svegliate quanto tempo è perfetto e ora
se ti alzi di tiro il coach caja stato
mangiato tutto collega porca vacca sono
lento c'è un vaso che mi aiuto mi ha
bloccato un passo non vale che è male
direi che ci siamo raga devo aver fatto
brevemente tutto l'ultima che rimane è
questa se passi di qui
dovrei aver finito ci ha messo un po di
tempo è però almeno gli ha fatto fuori
tutti
very good andiamo con luglio signori un
giorno senza aspirapolvere un giorno
perso signori
ricordatevi che centra il friday tra
poco quindi io farei un pensierino su
questi tipi di elettrodomestici
dici che sono poi antifurto al massimo
la gente hanno sempre più difficile però
andiamo avanti
aumentiamo la gente voglio vedere fin
dove riusciamo ad arrivare ragazza
allora stavolta sono in se ci sono i
coltelli per te non ne chiedono i
coltelli che prima facevano così tanto
danno perché prima non so cosa sia
successo facciamo danno a caso oggi
l'obiettivo ragazzi e farsi seguire da
tutti quanti in modo da farli fuori
tutti in una botta sola non è sempre
facile ma per giocatori esperti come me
questo ed altro il cammino il cammino il
camino cammino tutti quanti ebri bari
sul camino solo 11 prè ma come fai a
janò mi hanno circondato porca vacca
ragazzi mai farsi circondare in questo
gioco come se qualcuno ci giocasse
appartenenza
ok che due sono morti a caso come se
niente fosse a tre facciamo anche tre
macchinette del caffè signori molto bene
foolish heart di opera anche il frigo si
sa mai che qualcuno ci ha voglia di
passarci sopra agli aiuto no mi hai
messo la vita sola come questo è
successo
raga mi è rimasta solo una vita non so
chi no ora di capire non so che mi abbia
preso ma mi ha fatto malissimo
ok 1 ok 2 rombo che esplode questo pure
madonna che casino ragazzi ho fatto un
tanto incredibile 3 no madonna che
rischio
bellissimo bene bene bene bene ho già
fatto che danno allucinante ragazzi già
devo fare non è facile se impegnando da
matti ma c'è da fare
la madonna tutto a posto e vabbè ho
fatto dei danni che non so neanche io
però vabbè tutto ancora fattibile e
ragga ce l'ho fatta fatto fuori tutti
non so cosa sia successo per noi
teoricamente aver vinto con una vita di
scarto clean di house perfetto allora
prima ce n'erano 6c adesso dovrebbero
essercene sei ragazzi non ce la posso
fare con sette tori came ma ce n'è uno
invisibile ma no ragazzi ma è un bong
cose non accadono non ho capito se è un
bug allora ma cosa succede ai a tema le
non ragazzi non ho capito è un vago cosa
non vedo i nemici non vale non li vedo
aiace non avanti ma non ce la posso fare
non li vedo
devo arrangiarmi con le impronte hamas
ha inserito un ragazzino non ce la posso
fare non vedo niente aia e qua non ho
neanche non lo vedo ragazzi non li
vedono non si può fare un dio ce l'avevo
4 attorno ma come l'avevo 4 nora che
infattibile no ragazzi mi giurò che non
ho capito se mi ripetono che ce l'ho
fatta eccome
come ho fatto la cosa ha fatto a
vincerla impossibile l'ho vinta senza
avere la non ho capito se un bug davvero
è però importante vincere come si vede
cosa c'è dopo c'è però è impossibile
aumentiamo il numero già che ci siamo
entrate sono nani come solo nei binari
aia concludeva per nova venne
velocissimo ma e veloci non ce la posso
fare sono troppo veloci
oh mio dio e vabbè questo successo e
robben
no ragazzi
sono di che chi è che ha fatto le foto o
ad haga mia pezzente occhio molto bene
devo stare veramente istante perché sì
quella di far fuori molto bene
qualcuno ha preso qualcosa nel cesso man
mano come non l'ho colpito aiuto aiuto
non sono poi mangiato a posto no ora che
sto soffrendo ve lo giuro
sto veramente soffrendo levati di
qualche un casino poi è morto anche lui
bagnatelo bari good questo ma da quanto
lenti nove ragazzi ci metto veramente
troppo a far le cose
perfetto
pasqua passata sa qualcosa quando sa
qualcosa qua riattiva l'acqua un casino
è morto è morto con l'acqua a caso lo
vedo che si sta arrabbiando ma non è che
possa fare chissà che cosa
ma don me lo son bagnato dove aver vinto
è c'è ancora qualcuno ma veramente ma
come ok ce l'ho fatta
e stato molto difficile vi assicuro
credo ragazzi che livello dopo sia
quello ultimo quindi non so cosa ci sia
alla fine ma per adesso dire il computer
e qua veramente figo è stato lasciato un
bel mi piace se volete che il mio corpo
ricompaia nei prossimi video io vi
ringrazio ha visto video discrete le
classi non sera con gli scritti
schiacciata campanellina che è molto
importante
era come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video bella ragazza
[Musica]